is a man who plays dollar bills turn on
billions and I'm I'm pleased and honored
to be able to say I acted in a scene
with this man whose work we all enjoyed
back back in the day on house of cards
and I loved him on the Americans and
he's fantastic in billions he's Kelly a
coin how are you Kelly I'm good I'm good
a little worse for wear because of last
night but but I'm good that King was fun
wasn't it well you know what that scene
was unbelievable so I'm gonna give you
the dealer's choice first Kelly do you
want to talk about the scene or about
your your Blazers first let's get into
the depressing topic first well I mean
there's still you're not eliminated I
mean you still know so when taken we're
taking the game tomorrow don't get me
wrong it's going 7 ok crushes on Denver
but yeah that was that was not a great
way to follow up what's been up pretty
easy a pretty remarkable playoffs for
the Trailblazers well I mean the fact
that you guys lost Newark ik and then
we're able to get to where you are right
now based on what's happened the last
couple seasons I don't know if you
recall that house money or not but you
know I get I give you the floor to
represent the Blazer fan base there
right I suppose you could look at it
that way they just they've been playing
so well with Newark obviously and with
Newark and then picking up cancer they
had a path and whatever they mean
obviously they have a path there they
were they were tied 2-2 they were up to
one in them in this particular series
without Newark so when he went down it
was amazing that Kansas stepped up as
well as he had but then he you know he's
playing with one arm now so it's it may
be a house money situation I don't know
I find it perplexing that Damon CJ have
been his office they have in last couple
games or I guess did you not the game
before but you know I it's it's
definitely doable we are not the team
that we showed last night we have a lot
more resilience than that so I do I do
think we're coming back and winning
tonight well that said I mean you know
yo kitch is this dude he's seasoned he's
amazing
I mean you you know and Jamal Murray is
no obviously slouch but this get
joke it's we've been talking about
throughout the show he may be one of the
best second round picks ever yeah it's
shocking to me that he was a second
round pick it's its final and he's such
a I was just talking with Dan Soder who
plays Murphy on our show and he's a big
nuggets fan and he and I have this
rivalry going back and forth like he's
like he's like the goofiest superstar
you know like it whatever he does look
so lumbering and so like he looks like a
like it like it like the Doughboy is
shooting the shot and yet
the touch is so brilliant then he just
seems to be able to snag rebounds out of
thin air and he's phenomenal he's
phenomenal
and I in the trade that when we when we
traded Plumlee to them for room for
Newark it obviously was great for us but
you know Plumlee was a great backup guy
and it cleared the way for Yogesh to be
the obvious number one guy on their team
and that was a smart move for both teams
yeah I mean I take my hat off to two
Yogesh my my big quibble is that
apparently the referees think he's so
good set
extending the the forearm in in a manner
in which he shoves people off of him
doesn't seem to actually be a foul he's
that good he's already getting the
benefit Kelly he's already getting the
bat he's already getting the benefit but
yeah okay I'm gonna stop there [ __ ]
about the referees if we hadn't played
so poorly last night I don't think as a
man deserve to be able to pitch given
them give it a bad game Kelly a coin the
actor who plays dollar bill Stern on
billions diehard plays a fan here on the
Rich Eisen show and before we do move on
to what you just let slip there about
Dan Soder who plays Murphy and the scene
that I was so thrilled to be in I do
want to hit on Lillard for a second now
you live there in New York City I mean
you work there in New York City so you
have seen what the Knicks look like and
what Knicks fans have been going through
and waiting just waiting waiting for
some I'm Aaron's on their hands and
knees that Zion with the ping-pong balls
cuff falls their way or Durant shows up
what I hope you're not about to suggest
what I think you're no no no no no no no
what I'm suggesting is this what is it
like
routing for somebody like Damien Lord
having that guy as somebody that you can
turn on put your hopes into and then
have certainly against Oklahoma City him
deliver the way that he delivers oh yeah
no listen it's it's fantastic I mean the
guy he was a 1 thought he was going to
be good no one thought it was gonna be
this good some people didn't think he
didn't make the MBA actually he keeps
getting better every season even his
defense is actually adequate now you
know in the OKC series he actually
played good defense on on Westbrook kept
trying to rock the baby on him and I
loved one Dame was like you can't rock
the baby when it's like a turnaround
18-footer it doesn't count right but
it's great you know the other thing is
that he's he's he's a great leader he
makes the other players around him
better he he's like and he's like a big
brother figure to everybody it go down
the line and each one of the players are
like he's like people actually say stuff
like he's the best thing that ever
happened to me or he's the best thing
that ever happened to my career he has
made it very clear that he wants a
championship desperately but he also
wants to do it in Portland he wants to
do it that way and that that it's more
important for him to do that rather than
the chase of rank I mean for a small
market like Portland you know a
long-suffering market like Portland then
that's a that's music to your ears so
it's great I mean he becomes like
Portland is this way of and maybe other
fan bases do too Portland has this way
of becoming incredibly emotionally
attached to these guys it makes you feel
like they're brothers or or you know
parents or kids or whatever I think
there's a there's just a love affair
with with Damian right now and it's part
of what makes it great is that he seems
to return it yeah just that shot that he
made to put up 50 over Paul George the
guy who dumped at the last second and
their only win in that series waving
bye-bye
shooting it from the logo that that's an
alzheimer that is an and can I also make
it to make another area an observation
we go for that bad shot that was a bad
shot in his first first shot of the
series taken by any
any player any team was Damian from
essentially that same distance and it
went in in Game five the game where he
launched that 37 foot game where end of
the end of the second quarter
he hit a shot from almost exactly the
same spot over Paul George
so mr. George yes you were warned you
can't say that the bad shot when he was
8 for 12 for the series and he did it
over you twice Kelly a coin who plays
dollar bill Stern are billions here in
the Rich Eisen show ok now let's get to
this year are you telling me the week in
which the I won would say rivalry and
hatred building up between your
character dollar bill Stern and that of
the actor Dan Soder Murphy happens the
week that your favorite basketball team
the blazers plays his in the Nuggets in
the playoffs are you saying that
actually did work out between the sports
and billions gods Kelly your coin
shockingly it worked out between the
gods it's incredible we and I've been
talking about this rivalry for years and
we have a bet going back and forth to
the $20 bill is essentially it's been
even I guess kind of like the fight on
billions or there can't be a double loss
like there was I mean that scene was
unbelievable to finally see piece
together after it was shot over my god
the an entire calendar day in New York
City that was unbelievable Kelly it was
interesting to see how it was really fun
to see how they told the story because
we shot for so long yeah and then you
know everyone else was talking about how
funny you guys were but we couldn't hear
it so you know and and me I told you I
got my I broke my rib on the first take
of the first shot of the day now I can't
believe how are you yes yet
yes we rehearsed that thing for we
choreographed the hell out of it and we
rehearsed it for a month we had it down
but then you know you get in front
through the cameras there right actually
rolling and 300 extras eternal and gets
going and it's he tagged me and I
thought that that's not good
it was antagonizing until the next day
so you know I'd love to be able to say I
pulled a cantor and and pulled through
excruciating it wasn't that bad until
the next day because I couldn't tell at
all I mean no one great I couldn't tell
him were you medicating yourself
throughout the day Kelly uh I had a lot
of ibuprofen and there was a medic on
the set who sort of felt it I kept
people kept telling me Jonte Wilder who
was in my corner yes it was like no I
don't think it's broken
he wouldn't be able to move right now
and then afterwards I thought well his
his idea his threshold of pain is
probably a little higher than mine but
there was a medic that ya felt around
and she was like like she felt this
little cut chunking and she's like you
know that's that's not hmm not good so
you asked Deontay Wilder for you know he
doesn't play a doctor he's not one on TV
but clearly he is somebody who might
have been injured in a ring at some
point his life you Kelly a coin asked
him for just a little bit of a diagnosis
on the spot I I think I was just like I
don't know what's going on it might be
broken and he just you know he didn't he
didn't say he didn't say it's not I
think he just said no I don't think so
but look it was my I was given the
choice to go get an x-ray I was given a
choice to stop things then I mean it
would have been I think disastrous for
this I mean you saw how many how much
money they spent on that day oh my gosh
I'm back I can't imagine what they would
have done but but they gave me the
chance I my bosses are awesome they're
like health first you need to go you
need to go well that's how I got on the
show cuz I've known Brian Koppelman for
a while and I've been a fan of the show
since Jump Street literally since the
first frame you know and - I guess bring
everything together here it's like the
first shot of that show was like making
it from the logo it was amazing right
now like yeah and and I loved it and and
I've met David Levine through Brian and
I got a you know a text like December in
the middle of the football season hey we
have an opportunity for you to come on
billions are you up for it I'm like am I
out for it you know just
when and then I'm holding my breath
watching the dots show up on my phone is
because I know Brian's typing back and
I'm like please don't be during the
Super Bowl cuz that's the only time I
can't do it and he came back with a date
between the divisional and and and NFC
championship came weekend and I still
got to do this it's amazing you guys are
awesome
I'm seriously I mean though the whole
set is amazing the whole cast that I got
to meet just great Kelly it is right and
the crew everybody is fantastic it's so
everybody's so professional so on top of
their game
and for a show that is about toxic power
you know everyone is so damn nice it's
just a great group to hang out with
Brian and David are great bosses you
couldn't ask for better
the writing is a blast you know they the
characters keep evolving my character
certainly has it's just it's it's a
blast and you guys made me laugh out
loud I I did I did some ADR work on on
the fight yeah I knew what it looked
like
and I thought oh it's great it's great
and then when I was actually watching
the episode the night before it aired I
was laughing out loud it was I guess
that's that not entirely lead it's not
entirely legal yeah no that's
yeah that's not Lisa so just it was
hilarious thanks Kelly you said that I
can't say I do
they didn't they didn't they didn't use
some of my blue lines hey before I let
you go Kelly what what is your favorite
I mean what is your favorite dollar bill
stern moment where you think it's as low
as a human being can go but you played
it for the highest high I probably got
three that are hard to choose from now
the fake fight from the original said
the first season was the first real big
bill breakout moment mmm smashing re
Spiros his car and then and then the
fight you know it's really hard it's
really hard to top any of those well my
guy here Chris Brockman on the set who
you've seen on Twitter that people think
you guys look exactly alike here you're
a handsome and Kelly you're handsome in
you're a handsome man as well I really
we should go we should go like out
clubbing together and freak people out
dress the same and see the other react I
have to up my vest wardrobe but I'm
missing what's your favorite what's your
favorite doll oh it's just the whole
chicken episode from earlier this year
yeah it was amazing
awesome yeah that was that was a lot of
fun a lot of fun Kelly for the the whole
chicken part Kelly you're awesome in the
show it was great to meet you I hope you
know we stay in contact and for sure
you're the official Blazers go-to guy on
the Rich Eisen show that's a that's a
fact equiment yeah great to meet you too
and that's definitely stay in touch
you got it Kelly a coin who plays dollar
bills turn on billions hoping to get a
game 7 for his Blazers right here in the
Rich Eisen show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app